le mouvement de protestation des
employés municipaux du québec contre la
réforme de leur régime de retraites a
repris de plus belle quelques centaines
d'entre eux ont bloqué les accès à
l'hôtel de ville de montréal durant près
d'une heure ce midi une manifestation
bruyante qui est réservé une surprise au
maire denis coderre c'est ce qu'a
préparé olivier vachon
les employés municipaux affirment que la
ville veut leur arracher leur chemise
ils ont donc décidé de la remettre à
denis coderre en la lançant ce retard
vis de l'hôtel de ville
et pour son anniversaire ils lui ont
offert ce gâteau
rappelant qu'il ne digère pas le projet
de loi déposé par québec afin de
renflouer les régimes de retraite des
employés municipaux
les syndicats s'opposent farouchement au
partage 50/50 des déficits passés des
régimes de retraite entre les employés
les villes où plusieurs d'entre eux les
pertes financières pourraient être
considérables accomplis pendant environ
75 me de ventes en plus service passait
la hausse de cotisation pour avoir un
maillot un moins bon régime de retraite
à moins d'un mois de la commission
parlementaire qui doit se pencher sur le
projet de loin les employés municipaux
décident d'intensifier leurs moyens
pression partout au québec
chauffeurs d'autobus cols bleus et cols
blancs vont modifier leur uniforme
habituels comme l'ont déjà fait les
policiers et les pompiers qui portent
des jeans des tenues de camouflage
les syndicats craignent qu'il n'y ait
pas de place au compromis même si
certains régimes de retraite de près de
la vigueur
le maire quant à elle vers la gauche le
gouvernement compte lui adopté une loi
que pierre kamé plus sa place
de son côté la ville de montréal s'est
dit toujours d'accord avec les principes
du projet de loi bachelot
l'équité intergénérationnelle lui aussi
respecter la capacité des payeurs de
taxes la peau ce genre de régime
les employés municipaux vont poursuivre
leurs moyens de pression au cours des
prochaines semaines et promettent
d'autres coups d'éclat d'ici
v ou alors que débutera à la commission
parlementaire qui doit étudier le projet
de loi sur les régimes de retraites sur
les bâches en radio canada montréal